how did hit him with the hein start what
was the moment that it became this big
deal well when I go to do a second show
I host a sports talk show at SN Y here
at 5:30 when I would leave work one of
the guys there Nick Rucker would yell
hit him with behind because I'm kind of
tired and working my way over there and
then Jayson who sits next to Nick kind
of took it and kept saying it like
sarcastically like you have no energy so
go get him which kind of pissed me off
and then somehow that filtered into the
Howard world and Howard picked up on it
and that sports guy started using it and
then the next thing I know Joe Buck and
Jimmy Kimmel are yelling hit him with
the hind and tribute to the Howard Stern
Show and my name is all over the place
just because of the way I stand up and
walk out of the office so when you're
sitting there and you hear Jimmy Kimmel
like at the Emmys go we hit him with
behind you know as he's signing off and
what how does that strike you I know
used to kind of be resistant toward it
but what do you think when that is
happening and when your family name is
being shouted out at major sporting
events
well when Jimmy said it I was thrilled
because I knew it was just a shout out
to the Stern Show and it all depends on
the intent it's like anything else it's
why and the way that you're saying it so
when at sporting events and people yell
it out to celebrate I'm totally cool
with that I think it's great it's when
people yell it out to either mock me or
goof on me that's when I get a little
upset but it's been happening so much
I'm starting to build up a bababooey
kind of skin to not let it affect me on
a day-to-day basis I'm trying
have you ever shouted hit him with the
hein for for any reason no I've never
done it I feel like as the subject of it
it would be wrong of me to be the one
shouting it I'm always on the receiving
end and you asked about my family they
get a huge kick out of it they think
it's great that my name is not their
names all over the place so you wouldn't
do it spontaneously yourself but what if
I asked you to do it as we ended this
interview just to like break this record
of you never doing and here we are on
Power Hour what a great way to end the
interview would you care to hit him you
know if it was campus connection maybe
I'd do it
but I would be more than happy to give
you a bababooey if you're looking for
that you know what we'll take it and I
love the campus connection shout out and
this end us with Thea the original
saying go Baba Booey to you all